je me trouve devant la boutique le
parfum en herbe situé à saint germain en
laye ici on peut confectionner son
propre parfum grâce à l'aide et aux
conseils de marie pierre le car la
gérante du magasin allez suivez moi
marie pierre bonjour
alors on a à peu près deux heures pour
confectionner votre propre parfum au
café nous allons faire un petit peu
d'anatomie vous pourrez choisir votre
vaporisateur de parfum et après en face
kobe chimie création du parfum eva super
qu'on y va si on faisait partie
l'artiste
[Musique]
alors marie-pierre on va débuter cet
atelier olfactif oui voilà avec plaisir
donc on va commencer par un tout petit
peu d'anatomie pour bien comprendre le
système olfactif chaque fois que vous
sentez une odeur et on en sent en
continu toute la journée les odeurs
monte dans le nez se prennent dans ce
petit fils et olfactif et il ya un
message qui partent directement dans le
cerveau après un petit cours d'anatomie
on va maintenant faire des petits jeux
pour découvrir les essences de création
seulement avec l'odorat une expérience
un peu compliqué donc voilà un premier
petit s 2 rien merci donc juste un petit
filet on sent l'odeur qui montent donc
dans des parfums il peut y avoir des
fruits des fleurs des feuilles mais on a
plus de 1200 matière à notre disposition
qui sont naturels donc là c'est une
première catégorie qui est très
importante en parfumerie pour donner de
la fraîcheur au moins la famille des
fruits au moins la famille de fruits
donc c'est pas un frein agrumes c'est un
agrume un à l'agenda fait et maintenant
dans les agrumes
en tout je vais faire pas moins d'une
dizaine de senteurs différentes avec
plus ou moins de mal deuxième étape vous
allez choisir votre vaporisateur de
parfum j'ai choisi un format un peu
carré autre étape décorer son flacon
j'ai fait une ambiance bohème coeur
fleurs et papillons troisième étape la
création la composition de votre part
l'étape la plus importante dans un
parfum il ya trois classiquement trois
étapes la note de tête la note de coeur
et la note de fond on a parlé du nombre
de matières la disposition des
parfumeurs donc entre mille 3000
matières différentes donc je vous ai
fait des bases de création c'est à dire
qu'il ya déjà des notes qui sont
mélangés et qui s'équilibre comme il
faut il y a donc plus d'une centaine de
senteurs une dizaine par flatte mais
première étape les notes de tête le
choix entre deux accords ensuite la note
de coeur huit choix on doit en retenir 3
donc pendant que je fais cette petite
préparation et je me disais finalement
est-ce que le parfum qu'on choisit c'est
le reflet de notre personnalité
forcément c'est le reflet de votre
personnalité et c'est aussi souvent des
référents que vous avez c'est à dire
qu'on revient souvent à des notes qu'on
a aimés sur quelqu'un et c'est aussi
souvent leurs plaies d'une personnalité
vous êtes très exubérant vous avez envie
d'un parfum de cuisson fort pour vous
faire remarquer un peu
vous êtes de nature très calme nous
allons peut-être chercher un parfum
vraiment cocooning pour vous simplement
pas là simplement pour épater la galerie
un petit cours de chimie commence
béchère équipe est en main je dois donc
doser en mettant plus ou moins 200
heures en fonction des notes de tête des
notes de coeur des nattes deux ans
voilà j'ai fini j'ai mon flacon en main
finalement c'est assez simple il suffit
de choisir les senteurs que vous
préférez maintenant si vous voulez vous
aussi créer votre propre parfum rendez
vous sur le site internet de la boutique
allez moi je morente 2
[Musique]